además de concluir esto que Boris
Johnson mintió deliberadamente al
parlamento sobre el caso del partygate
Cuáles son las recomendaciones de este
comité
Buenas tardes recomendó que si Johnson
no hubiera renunciado como lo hizo el
viernes pasado hubiera suspendido su
hubiera sido suspendido Por 90 días que
es un castigo mucho mayor de lo que se
esperaba porque automáticamente casi
perdería su silla en el parlamento
británico como lo mencionaba se concluyó
en este informe que Johnson mintió no
solamente una sino varias veces en lo
que él llamó reuniones de trabajo porque
se rompieron todas las leyes del
distanciamiento Social esta
recomendación es bien bien interesante y
extraordinaria porque la recomienda que
Boris Johnson no obtenga el pase de
exdiputado lo que evitaría que ingresara
fácilmente al edificio de Westminster
Esta es en esencia una investigación
política que tendrá que ser votada el
próximo lunes y así se sabrá si los
solidarios conservadores de Johnson aún
mantienen su papel mantienen el apoyo o
si ya están con el actual Primer
Ministro Richie sunat
Luisa nos lo decía ahora quizás a
Johnson pierde esta credencial de
exdiputado Pero cuál es el impacto de
esta decisión en la carrera política de
Johnson a futuro digamos
es un hecho sin precedentes en la ya
política caótica del Reino Unido que
hemos presenciado en el último año
prestamos hablando de una figura tan
popular como tan controversial que hace
menos de un año era el inquilino de
Downey Street la sede del gobierno
británico y como lo dices tiene un
impacto enorme no solamente en el futuro
del partido conservador sino de Johnson
mismo porque en su carta de renuncia del
viernes dice que está muy triste de
salir del parlamento por un tiempo pero
dice que regresará no hay certeza en el
Cómo ni en el cuándo hace apenas unas
horas un analista político me dijo que
la paciencia del partido conservador en
el caso de Johnson se está agotando y no
hay certeza tampoco de cómo vaya a
reaccionar con esta investigación el
sector Pro Johnson del partido
conservador que lo ha apoyado durante
todos los escándalos justamente
Johnson apenas conoció estos resultados
dijo que hoy era un día muy triste para
la democracia mecánica y su respuesta
está llena de calificativos como
mentiras basuras y dice que en su caso
se está cometiendo un asesinato político